salut il ya une formule très précises
qui apparemment permet de calculer le
blue monday c'est à dire le jour où tu
seras le plus dépressive dans l'année
c'est cliff arnal qui est à l'origine de
cette équation il était professeur à
l'université de cardiff et il a créé une
formule très précises w plus grande et
moins petits des fois tu es tu sûr m x
m alors ewc la météo grande et c'est le
taux d'endettement petit décès le
salaire mensuel de la personne
grant et c'est le temps qui s'est écoulé
depuis noël grand cul c'est le temps
passé depuis le dernier gros échec de
cette personne
mc son niveau de motivation et enas et
la nécessité d'agir et cette formule est
reprise régulièrement sur les sites sur
les blogs même dans la presse plus
sérieuse ou des journaux un peu plus
sérieux alors que cette formule n'a
aucun aucun aucun fondement scientifique
des experts en sciences qu'ils ont
appelé la bêtise absolue parce qu'en
fait cette équation elle a pris des
proportions un peu démesuré c'est ce qui
se passe parfois avec les pseudo science
et du coup l'université de cardiff a
publié dans un premier temps un
communiqué en précisant qu'en fait ils
étaient juste professeur à mi-temps et
puis après ils ont fait un autre
communiqué plus tard ou disait non mais
en fait on le on le connaît pas non non
non
et la réalité finale elle est très drôle
en fait il avait juste fait ça pour une
campagne marketing comme ça faisait très
sérieux il ya des gens qui ont pris ça
au pied de la lettre et qui encore
aujourd'hui propagent cette équation qui
a pas de sens comme quoi si vous voulez
faire une équation vous même vous prenez
des grosses lettres vous donner un sens
aux grosses lettres et puis vous publiez
ça et ça peut le faire et moi de mon
côté je vous donne rendez-vous après
demain n'oubliez pas de cliquer de vous
abonner si ce n'est pas déjà fait une
vidéo tous les deux jours jusqu'au 30
août
ciao
[Musique]